and welcome back everybody well the
Associated Press has released its 2022
photos of the Year 150 of the most
impactful images from across the world
as this year comes to a close we take a
closer look at some of the moments
captured on camera that shed light on
where we are and where we're going
from disasters both natural and man-made
to the awe-inspiring and even surreal
the ap's annual year in review
highlights their top photos showing
tragedy and hope in Ukraine and striking
moments from China there is one from the
Olympics in Beijing Nina Berman is a
journalism professor at Columbia
University that picture did what great
pictures do which was it was about the
event but it was about something totally
different as well which was about global
warming urbanization where are
snow-capped mountains right like where
is this this total dislocation that
dislocation may be a new normal with the
U.N projecting increased heat waves
drought wildfires and more intense
storms like hurricane Ian which ravaged
Cuba in late September Havana based
photographer Ramon Espinosa covered the
aftermath
the town of La Coloma he says was the
most affected by the hurricane it
completely destroyed the school and
soaked all the books if the teacher had
not put the books out to dry possibly
the kids would not have a way to study
again this year especially due to the
rather precarious economic situation in
Cuba Espinosa has six images in the ap's
wrap-up the highest number among the
photographers included I asked him if he
knows when he gets the perfect shot
yes he says normally a shiver runs
through me my process of work is a
little contrary to the times basically
most of the time I work with manual
lenses precisely because of that feeling
of looking for it all the time so how do
you teach you know people to look for
these things but part of it is you just
have to start doing it right so it's
almost a muscle memory memory you start
to understand how maybe people will move
how things unfold so photojournalists
live in the moment that is part of what
we love like this moment capture by Jay
Hong at a memorial for victims of the
school shooting in Uvalde Texas the
deadliest mass shooting of 2022. what
grabbed my attention was that little
girl's fingers around her mother is so
the intensity of the event that the
tragic event so I made a few pictures
and walked away Hong is featured four
times this year including this from his
photo essay on homelessness and
addiction in Los Angeles he says walking
away is never easy there has to be an
incredible amount of one empathy and
also humility how do you go about
documenting it I'm asking myself that
question all the time how do I do this
how do I approach this it's hard you
know sometimes I use a a mirrorless
camera it's fairly light but then
sometimes it feels like I'm carrying a
a 40 pound dumbbell what I capture is
subtraction of what I saw and what I saw
is just a fraction of
what's going on day and night out there
on the street and yet these photos speak
volumes what role do you think
photojournalists have in showing us
essentially who we are well just like
close your eyes for a second and
consider the internet without photos
right or consider news without photos
apologies to writers out there but
honestly like there would be nothing we
would have no ability to connect with
each other the way photography does
and these are the moments that they did
capture several of them told me there
are times when they have the perfect
shot that they never take yeah reminds
me of that movie The Secret Life of
Walter Mitty Sean Penn says the same
thing about his he's a photographer in
that moment when we see these we see the
photos but you don't see the com we
don't talk about the countless hours
they put in oh yeah waiting the patients
involved the work the travel everything
else a picture's worth a thousand words
okay sometimes more yeah that's right
absolutely